before we go we want to take a moment to
honor someone who was an instrumental
part of our cbs news family longtime
photojournalist george christian died
over the weekend
throughout his more than 40-year career
he helped us document iconic moments all
over the world from the fall of the
berlin wall to nelson mandela's release
from prison
and his election as south africa's
president
christian was on air force one with
president bush on 9 11 covered
presidents clinton clinton's time in
office and witnessed president nixon's
resignation he talked about that in an
interview with chip reid back in 2014.
i've been fortunate enough to be in
places where i would have paid cbs to be
there
this was one of them and i would have
paid a lot and i think a lot of people
would you had a front row seat on
history i had a front row seat i wasn't
sitting there
i was standing hiding behind the
camera george christian earned an emmy
award and a special lifetime achievement
award from the radio and television
correspondents association for all of
his
incredible work our hearts go out to his
family george shot the first piece i
ever did for cbs news and he was on the
head on camera for face the nation he
was a good he was a man he was a kind
and talented guy part of the fun of
going to the washington bureau is you
get to see him his smiling face and he
was always so welcoming and whenever you
see
somebody like that and you hear their
voice it just sort of brings you back
and he's like so you know so many we
work with who
those of you out there don't see yeah
but they make us who we are and what we
are not just on tv but he george
christian was a good man who made you
better even when you weren't on tv what
a wonderful career and what a great
advertisement for the profession you
know berlin wall south africa multiple
presidents dixon resignation this
incredible life
and to see him in his suit and tie
standing behind the camera
i always say i always think that's nice
george you will be missed our
condolences again to your family